so last week I did a story which was me  talking about Joe Biden's approval  rating Joe Biden's approval rating is in  Trump's favorite place the toilet and I  do a show about National politics we  talk about the president so when I  covered George W bush I would report on  his approval rating wasn't my opinion I  didn't do the poll I just report on it  when Barack Obama was President I would  report on the approval rating when Trump  was President I would report on the  approval rating and it's the same thing  with Biden and I got so many angry  emails from people on the left saying  David how dare you say Biden is bad I  didn't say Joe Biden's bad I said he has  a low approval rating which is true  David what you don't want uh you don't  think Joe Biden's doing a good job  because he hasn't given everybody ponies  I actually got that email no it's not my  opinion I'm just reporting on the  approval rating guys do we understand  the difference between the messenger and  the message